votre nationalité, votre sexe, votre race,
elles nous appartiennent
et se battre pour la justesse n'est pas un acte de folie.
Les entreprises doivent participer au programme.
Un investissement d'entreprise dans les droits de l'Homme est un gain capital,
et que vous soyez une entreprise, une ONG,
un citoyen, l'État de droit nous avantage tous.
En travaillant ensemble avec une même mentalité,
à travers le peuple, le secteur public et privé,
nous pouvons créer une économie des droits de l'Homme,
et nous pouvons tous devenir des investisseurs dans les droits de l'Homme.
En faisant ça,
nous pouvons atteindre la justesse ensemble.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)